you know robert duvall says sending me
years ago and he's been a mentor to me
and and he he said something that really
struck me it's a real popular thing to
say with you know critics that oh this
person or that person is a wonderful
actor because they're so underplayed and
so understated
well in fact life's not like that I mean
you know look at you know some of the
characters you see in real life like in
politics or whatever it is you know
there are moments that you might do
something as an actor and something that
that a critic liked who thinks that
might say oh that was over the top but
life is over the top and life is subtle
sometimes and Duvall tell me one time
you said there's a very thin line
between subtle and boring yeah and
sometimes you know you see people just
you know do the sort of actor voice for
two and a half hours and it's like oh
come on dude you know and it's like yes
you see one more thing I know I'm a man
but I'm pregnant
or whatever it is it's like you know
after two and a half hours that you're
like you know every now and then yell at
somebody well yeah yeah yeah
figure out who this character is not
just be this that sounds lame to just do
it one kind of dream line deal yeah and
there are times when it's called for and
it works I mean you know examples in my
career but in the man who wasn't there
the Coen Brothers and in Fargo was gonna
ask you about Fargo because how did you
know because you do Fargo how did you
know that that would work for the same
reasons that you wouldn't have done the
Friday Night Lights TV show do you know
what I mean that it wasn't this rehash
of this great film but something new
that would I mean you can probably tell
by looking at me I'm a massive Fargo fan
too but it's like it it turned into one
of the best seasons of TV ever that was
that was a real decision to make I mean
you know I know those guys the Coen
brothers have worked with him several
times and they're friends of mine and
and I did make a call and asked him if
they were cool with with it you know
getting their blessing if you will and
they what it wouldn't meant something to
me is when I read the script and they
did say yeah yeah we're on board of this
I read the pilot script and it was
really good I mean it wasn't something
that you had to go in there every day
and think hey I gotta fix this thing up
a little bit I just did what was there
the only thing I brought to the
character was they he was probably they
were probably expecting a little bit
more out there bad guy you know probably
a loud or a bad guy but early on there
was something in the writing that told
me this guy was just sort of a ghost
it's like is he real or not
is it gonna disappear one day yeah it
was yeah you really didn't know what to
make of a dispersed and the scene like
at the end in the Elat when he knows
that he's been found yeah like that
scene where you see real look you see
finally some real emotion like you're
really angry yeah that you've been found
and you did you left this guy behind
that whole life is over
yeah and now you have to actually deal
with this there's just this one like
those little moments where you're like
exactly and he's that's who he is that's
who he is as a person he's furious
excited he has to deal with this now and
he becomes very murderous very quickly
oh yeah yeah and as a killer he knows
that he has to be a ghost he has to be
an animal because he really he's the
perfect example of a human being being
as close to the animal kingdom as you
can be yeah you know he actually is kind
of a wolf and heals he'll sneak up on
you and if you mess with him in an
elevator if you happen to be a bystander
he will just take care of you and Martin
Freeman was was was perfect as the guy
to take on you know there were William H
may see like traits but it wasn't too
similar that you were like oh I get what
they're going for exactly Norton did a
great job